movie sequels get a bad rap but every
now and then one comes along that
totally blows its predecessor away which
comic-based franchise found its
direction with the help of a morally
ambiguous love interest keep watching to
find out
gremlins is a classic but it's also a
dark cynical little film it establishes
an idyllic it's a wonderful life-esque
setting and then has ugly little
monsters destroy the whole thing
gremlins 2 the new batch is a wholly
different animal
it moves the setting to a high-tech
skyscraper in new york city introducing
a far zanier cast of gremlins who wreak
a much sillier sort of havoc thanks to a
geneticist whose experiments lead to a
much wider variety of gremlin shapes and
sizes
gremlins was fun but as kean peel
pointed out gremlins 2 is completely
bananas in a way that makes it awesome
this
is g2 people we write in gremlins 2 it
should be a party
and even all these years later it's
exactly what hollywood should do
whenever it's time to drop a deuce
chris hemsworth has always been
charismatic and funny as thor odinson
the asgardian god of thunder and the
avengers resident himbo in fact he's
probably the best part of 2011's thor a
movie that has a lot going for it but
never quite lives up to its potential
despite the work of hemsworth and a
star-making turn from tom hiddleston as
loki a mix of mythic fantasy superhero
action and a fish out of water romantic
comedy it remains less than the sum of
its parts and is perhaps a bit clunkier
than it ought to be the 2013 sequel thor
the dark world seemed to double down on
this clunkiness with arguably the mcu's
worst villain ever and a macguffin that
made no sense even for the mcu
then came the third movie thor ragnarok
and finally things got on track
shifting directors from kenneth branagh
to alan taylor to taika ytt these movies
clearly reflected whoever was in the
chair
ragnarok brought a ytt-esque unorthodox
buoyancy to the series that felt like an
injection of buttery popcorn directly
into the vein
thor and loki are relocated far away
from both the overwrought fantasy of
asgard and the mundanity of earth
setting the second act of the movie
instead on the weird junkyard planet of
sakaar ruled by jeff goldblum's campy
grandmaster the mcu had never seen
anything like this before for the first
time thor and loki had a plot as fun as
their characters plus the hulk played by
mark ruffalo and valkyrie played by
tessa thompson memorably came along for
the ride the stakes were as high as ever
or higher considering asgard was being
threatened with complete destruction
nevertheless the storytelling in
ragnarok allowed for a lot more fun and
a level of knowing ridiculousness that
helped the whole mythic space gods
concept go down just a little bit easier
i just couldn't help myself i know i'm a
trickster
so mischievous
david ayers 2016 suicide squad was a
mess to start with it was the third film
in the dcu arriving the year before
justice league that meant ayer had the
unenviable task of introducing an entire
team of incarcerated super villains in a
world where audiences had barely met any
of the superheroes let alone their
enemies even though suicide squad spends
at least half its run time on multiple
sequences designed to introduce the team
most of the characters remain sketchy
and underdeveloped at best when the plot
finally does get going it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense furthermore main
villain enchantress played by cara
delevingne was one of the villains that
amanda waller played by viola davis had
recruited for the team so it really
calls into question why her idea of a
supervillain task force ever seemed like
a good idea to anybody
needless to say the whole thing was a
bad idea
despite being just plain terrible
suicide squad did uncover a tremendous
hunger for an offbeat film about these
dc anti-heroes in the aftermath of
batman vs superman warner brothers took
footage from ayer's somber film and put
together a fun breezy trailer that went
viral it was as if someone had made a
fan-produced cut of suicide squad as a
comedy but the resulting tug of war
between director and studio ultimately
resulted in a disjointed unsure of
itself debacle enter the king of offbeat
james gunn's 2021 the suicide squad with
the all-important definite article in
the title is a whole lot better it
brings in a bunch of new team members
like bloodsport played by idris elba and
peacemaker played by john cena all
funnier and more well-developed his
characters than anybody from the first
film it also capitalized on margot
robbie as harley quinn who had been the
best part of the first movie and then
had another movie in between birds of
prey to develop as a character and gain
new fans with a better script better
cast better direction and a clearer
sense of the dc extended universe as a
whole it's no surprise that the suicide
squad became a vast improvement over its
v-less predecessor
a live-action cgi family movie based on
the classic children's character
paddington bear is exactly the sort of
film you'd expect to get made these days
what nobody saw coming was that 2014's
paddington turned out to be absolutely
delightful retaining the quaint charm
and warmth of the original stories it
also boasted a truly stellar cast with
ben wishaw as the voice of the bear
sally hawkins and hugh bonneville as the
couple that welcomed him into their
family and nicole kidman as a villainous
taxidermist the movie charmed both
children and adults earning a truly
impressive 97 percent on rotten tomatoes
paddington was so beloved by its
audience that it's all the more
impressive that 2017's paddington 2
turned out to be even better than the
first film it earned an almost unheard
of 99 on rotten tomatoes that ranks it
among the most acclaimed films of all
time consider this paddington and
paddington 2 have a higher cumulative
rotten tomato score than the godfather
at 97 percent and the godfather 2 at 96
percent
the sequel centered on paddington being
framed for a crime and sent to prison
might sound like a bit of a bummer
however as the little bear's charisma
wins over hardened inmates it becomes
the sort of film that renews your faith
in humanity humor love and kindness with
hugh grant and brynden gleason joining
the already impressive cast paddington 2
might be as perfect a family film as
you're ever likely to see
magic mike is a stephen soderbergh drama
about a male stripper who doesn't want
to be a stripper anymore magic mike xxl
directed by gregory jacobs with
soderberg as a producer is a movie about
the joys of being a male stripper well
there was a lot of fun to be had in the
first movie the sequel puts that fun at
the forefront it portrays a kind of easy
going comfortable masculinity that isn't
threatened by putting one's body on
display for the pleasure of others
that's the mikey i remember
unsurprisingly the biggest fans of xxl
were women who flocked to the movie in
groups almost as if they were going to
an actual male strip club albeit one
populated by some of the most handsome
actors in hollywood visual pleasure is
central to film as a medium and few
films have made that pleasure as central
or as visceral as magic mike xxl
while 2014's godzilla was a huge
improvement over the previous attempt to
recreate the japanese monster for
american audiences it didn't exactly set
the world on fire godzilla looked great
but the monsters he thought were generic
and bore little resemblance to the
unforgettable foes he faced in the
original japanese series of films
furthermore the soldier played by aaron
taylor johnson was equally milk toast it
was about as forgettable of a human
protagonist monster movie as we've ever
seen this was a problem that was made
even more glaring by the lack of screen
time for the giant lizard everybody had
paid to see nevertheless the movie was
enough of a hit for legendary pictures
to move forward with their plans to make
godzilla the center of a monster verse
franchise
the next film in that franchise was
2017's kong skull island but it was a
prequel that didn't even involve
godzilla directly a direct sequel to the
2014 film didn't arrive until godzilla
king of the monsters in 2019.
fortunately it arrived with everything
godzilla's previous effort was missing
the classic monsters mothra rhoden and
king ghidorah all made their return to
kick off a globe-spanning giant monster
battle royale with a kind of monster
fighting action godzilla fans crave king
of the monsters also brought in kyle
chandler vera farmiga and millie bobby
brown to lead the human cast as a family
being torn apart in the midst of the
apocalyptic monster conflict whether
this americanized ceres is your cup of
tea or not it's hard to deny that
godzilla king of the monsters improves
on godzilla on basically every level
house of a thousand corpses the feature
directing debut of rocker robbed zombie
was a fun movie for horror fans so over
the top that it played more like an
ultra violent cartoon than a serious
film of any sort the titular house
occupied by the murderous firefly family
became a treacherous last stand for two
young couples with the misfortune of
ending up there on halloween night
zombie's tribute to the sort of
low-budget grindhouse horror movies he
grew up on the film never really
attempted to be more than that
nevertheless the film was a success so
zombie jumped at the opportunity to make
a sequel becoming considerably more
ambitious
the devil's rejects opens with the
destruction of the firefly house in a
police raid and the movie focuses on
three family members who escape and go
on the lamb while every bit as violent
as its predecessor the devil's rejects
abandons the cartoonish tone for an
atmospheric 1970s inflected road movie
with the soundtrack of classic southern
rock if horrific violence isn't your
thing this movie probably still isn't
for you but if it was the overall
ridiculousness of house of a thousand
corpses that turned you off the devil's
rejects might be exactly your thing
which wolverine movie was logan an
improvement on how about practically all
of them the x-men movie franchise first
introduced hugh jackman as logan the
nigh indestructible mutant with metal
claws in 2000's x-men also known as
wolverine he had his own solo films
before james mangold came along 2009's
x-men origins wolverine and 2013's the
wolverine however this western tinged
goodbye to the character was absolutely
transcendent to the point where some
regard logan as not just the best film
in the x-men franchise but the best
superhero movie of them all in any case
x-men origins wolverine is a nonsensical
mess and the wolverine is merely a
pretty good superhero action movie
differently logan is a genuinely moving
story about an aging hero dealing with
his own mortality and the apparent loss
of the hope he and his fellow x-men once
fought for
into this apocalyptic landscape arrives
laura a young girl in need of protection
who has far more in common with logan
than he expected naturally she brings
his long-buried heroic spirit back to
the fore and the old man once known as
wolverine makes one last stand
owing as much to westerns as it does to
the x-men movies logan is about as good
as superhero films can get
it took the fast and furious movies a
few installments to figure out exactly
what it wanted to be
the first film 2001's the fast and the
furious was a relatively straightforward
crime drama set in the world of street
racing starring paul walker vin diesel
michelle rodriguez and jordana brewster
only walker returned for 2003's too fast
too furious which filled out the cast
with tyrese gibson and chris ludacris
bridges for another story about crime
and racing the third movie the fast and
the furious tokyo drift left all of the
previous characters behind in service of
a story about an american teen played by
lucas black involved in street racing in
japan tokyo drift ended with a cameo
from vin diesel however and drift
director justin lin would turn out to be
instrumental in shaping the franchise's
future he would return as would diesel
and walker for the fourth film fast and
furious and 2011's fast five brought it
all together
justin lin directed once again and with
walker diesel brewster tyrese and
ludicrous the franchise was finally
firing on all cylinders also along for
the ride was dwayne the rock johnson as
a u.s government agent hunting the
protagonists the men we're after are
professional runners they like speed and
guaranteed to go down the hardest
possible way so make sure you've got
your thunder wear on
fast five's over the top heist plot put
the hot rods to new use and became a
huge hit but it also crafted a blueprint
for future installments of this series
each going bigger than the last even
still fast five is probably still the
best and there's not many franchises
that can say the fourth sequel was their
best film
the 1968 george romero classic knight of
the living dead remains a great film
both on its own merits and as the birth
of the modern zombie genre that stands
today
they're coming to get you barbara
it's a cross-media cash cow that extends
from the walking dead to left for dead
to army of the dead despite an
effectively grim atmosphere and talented
cast however its budget was tiny and
ambitions small
although the zombie problem appears in
night to be widespread the movie is
focused entirely on a small group of
people holed up in a rural farmhouse
they are attempting to hold the dead at
bay with only vague hints that something
far greater is going on in the rest of
the world
by the time romero returned to the
zombie narrative for 1978's dawn of the
dead he had more resources to play with
after a brutal opening showing how the
zombie infestation has devastated
low-income communities in philadelphia
the movie follows two cops and a pair of
tv journalists as they flee the city and
find refuge in a suburban mall although
the main cast is even smaller than that
of his 1968 film romero's reality now
feels much bigger and the threat that
much more real
although the group manages to secure the
maul against the hordes this apocalyptic
temple to capitalism wasn't made to
serve as a fortress the tension becomes
palpable as the living dead storm the
gates
1995's bad boys was the debut movie from
michael bay yes the rockstar music video
filmmaker who would reshape hollywood
with his glossy visuals adrenaline
pumping spectacle over story aesthetic
and belief that when all else fails just
blow something up it all began for
better or worse with this one
bad boys stars will smith and martin
lawrence as two reckless cops protecting
a witness and trying to find a large
amount of heroin that disappeared from
their police station the movie combines
comedy and over-the-top action into a
frothy thrill ride in cinematic form
it's a style bay would perfect in the
years to come with crowd-pleasing
spectacles like the rock and armageddon
by the time he made bad boys 2 in 2003
bay was riding high at the top of his
game and that's reflected in the product
bad boys 2 was bigger in scale than the
first movie from the explosions to the
amount of missing drugs on the other
hand it didn't forget the importance of
lawrence and smith's chemistry and the
appeal of their characters its
introduction of gabrielle union as sid
added a whole new level of conflict
while bad boys was a fun time every
facet of the film was heightened in bad
boys too
striking a balance that kept it from
being too big or loud making it simply
fun to watch
yeah i can see that
although it was a monstrously huge hit
at the time 1989's batman is in
retrospect a bit of an odd duck it's a
superhero film sure but outside of the
christopher reeves superman series
superhero films weren't really much of a
defined thing yet
batman contains a surprising amount of
80s action movie dna which pulls it away
from the conventions of comic book
storytelling
meaning there's a villain revealed to be
responsible for the hero's parents
deaths the hero revealing his secrets to
his love interest a climactic fight in a
tower that ends with the villain falling
to his death on the other hand director
tim burton put a lot of his oddball
gothic style into the film it became
distinctive enough to briefly foreshadow
a superhero film revolution that
wouldn't truly take hold until more than
a decade later by the time he directed
1992's batman returns burton had a lot
more freedom to bend the project to his
own aesthetic and narrative whims
consequently batman returns is also an
odd duck but one with a much clearer
vision it's set at christmas with lots
of atmospheric snow and statues of
angels the new villain the penguin
played by danny devito is a former
circus freak whose henchmen are all
weird carnies the grotesquery of the
penguin is juxtaposed with the far more
appealing morally ambiguous catwoman
played by michelle pfeiffer who's both
an enemy and a love interest for batman
christopher walken also appears as evil
businessman max shrek
giving one of the most walk-in-esque
performances of his life
the whole thing is a weird spooky campy
delight
and you can tell it's exactly what
burton wanted it to be
visionary director james whale didn't
want to make a second frankenstein movie
even though the first had been a smash
hit the studio finally convinced him by
letting him do pretty much whatever he
wanted the result was bride of
frankenstein an arch deliberately campy
outing that's generally regarded as the
first horror comedy whale paired the
high-strung dr frankenstein with a new
scientist named dr pertorius a proud
degenerate who gleefully defies the laws
of nature he also gave the monster the
power of speech which he had in the
novel but lacked in the original film
there's still plenty of pathos in bride
particularly the extremely dark ending
but it's balanced with a levity that the
original lacks making for a much
stronger film
this was whale's last frankenstein movie
and is widely regarded as the highlight
of the franchise
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]